it starts off really really simple okay
so let's just begin nice and gently so
you can get a little comfortable with
this idea okay if you have a look at
this second row inkyung okay because n
it can change around the community
values which have a value one right
really all you need is a empty the first
term and the common difference and that
defines out your entire AP okay so
therefore if I know what the first term
and the common difference are I can know
you can ask me anything you like about
this AP and I can tell you everything
right so for example let's write the
first four times that's pretty easy
you've already got the first turn it's
just 15 something to say the first terms
I begin with my 15 and then just get to
the next one that common difference it
includes sign in it right so it's
positive it could be negative as well
but in this case I have positive 3 so
the next one is just going to be from my
patent plus 3 right which is 18 and then
you get to the next one I had 3 and then
you get to the next one and I've done
first 4 terms there's nothing really to
it okay how do I get to the 50th term
right well firstly I have language just
to write down I don't just to save 50
return I can just say see 50 and I'm
going to appeal to my formula here
rather than write out the other 30
however many 45 values on top of that
right I don't need to go through a
recursive way I'm just going to go
straight to this because I've been
unfamiliar with it I'm just going to go
ahead and write
the actual general formula because
that's worth getting into my head and
then I'm going to sub in the piece of
information I need
so what did I say the first term is 15
plus 50 take one out of three yeah let's
see 49 lots of three that's gonna be
just one lakh shy of 150 so time to in
47 15 plus 147 smells like a hundred
sixty two right can I say by the way and
we will we'll keep well this will come
up again and again one of the great
things about ApS in the other kinds of
sequences we'll talk about later
is that you you want to use some of your
intuition here not to get the answer but
to know that the answer that you get is
within the realm of expectation right
you know what we call a common sense
check I would just see to two you can
verify that in your calculator but it
looks like it's in the ballpark to that
let's have a look at this guy man
outgoing from the other it sure that the
sequence you've been given is an AP and
it's slightly different find the first
negative term not fine where it comes up
they will need that but find out what is
the actual value now hopefully you can
guess a little bit again what does this
smell like what is it likely going to
get to its first negative we will verify
your instance or you know show that
they're all in a second I think you
might be able to guess how do we show
today P I'm going to my test down here
right I need to check that these two
pairs of terms these two of these two
have the same common difference okay so
the first thing I'm going to do is
remember yesterday when I talked to you
about be able to automating ultimately
all today you have money series I said
it's really important to get Auto right
order is everything right so please
don't do I hope you take away 92 like
this not complicated mathematics but if
you've put a hundred take one I do
don't really get what's going on and how
important the order is to this right so
I think what matters that's named eight
okay then you do the second pan here
please don't fudge like I know that
you're expecting it to be negative eight
okay so don't just write down negative
eight that's kind of already given to
you you need to sure even though it
seems a bit trivial I'm gonna take the
extra three seconds it takes to write
down 84 take away nine - so I know where
my negative eight is coming from okay ha
it's done so therefore
finished okay now I shown that it's an
AP the reason why I want to show there's
an AP is because now I can assume all of
the a peach stuff about this sequence
and I can use it to solve the second
part okay so this is not just tribute
like I can't assume any of this is true
until I know this is true right so let's
have a go this next part find the first
negative term hmm before I spy this for
you how might you go about solving this
like I'm actually going to give you a
couple minutes to how to think about it
chart your own path through this is all
this stuff that you know which of these
things new information is going to be
most useful to you and trying to tackle
that problem okay I think you have
enough pieces to solve the question when
you have a shot the first thing you need
to work out and I'm deliberately trying
not to just hand this to your summer
planet they're like I feel like there's
enough here that you can see what
directly going the best thing to do is
from this question what in your enormous
bank of knowledge which is going to get
bigger and bigger trust me what piece of
knowledge can I used to apply to this
question right now the first tactic is
you look at this and you think okay
first negative term there are my
keywords and I've highlighted underlined
okay clearly I'm really interested in a
single turn right one term so when I
have a look at this right well I've
already done this so that's the question
out of the question right do I want to
go via recursion well I don't know again
going to my instance how many terms my
life we'd have to go to get through this
well there are 25 lots of 4 in 100 so
I'm gonna need like 11 or 12 more terms
to get to down to a negative I don't
really want to work out that many
therefore this formula looks like the
best candidate for what can give me an
ounce or two reckoning quickly now to
get a formula of course I need to know
what a and D are right so I'm going to
say TM n is
and you know what AMDR right whatever
it's just 100 I've got n minus-1 lots of
what we just did this in the first part
right negative 8 okay so I've got um
I've got my term my intern shut up I
might as well because I can - I'll
simplify this guy just continuing it
what's gonna happen you I'm gonna have
100 plus and I'm just gonna write this
looks to me like it'll make you happy
with that
yep so that's so far so good
okay now what do I actually want this
thing should be I know there is some
term and some tmn that hits negative
actually there's an infinite number but
I just want the first one that's not the
first one right so I'm going to say I
want CNN she'd be negative okay that's a
crucial step right in inequality doesn't
necessarily jump at ease but that's what
I really want to solve right so I know
what teaming is so I can do substitution
and now I've now heard this since you
want relatively trivial question okay
now once you go ahead and you crunch the
numbers okay you're going to get it
turns around why does it turn around
there's two reasons why the first reason
why is because I have to divide by name
right so clearly that's going to switch
things yeah but secondly more
importantly remember I said there's an
infinite number of terms such that the
term - negative does that make sense
well it has to be greater than if I want
an infinite number of terms right
because it is said any number right say
n were less than 20 well that means
there's a finite number of terms that
satisfies this inequality but that can't
be true because I know there will be an
infinite number of terms I'll hit the
negative and then everything after that
will also be negative right so just
think about this you know so many times
we get an inequality just faces the
wrong direction think about what it
means when inequalities one way or
another what value do you get that get a
fraction right
95 13.5 ok now because we know we spent
the effort to say and has to be a
positive integer and I want the first
value that satisfies this the first
positive integer that's great in 13 and
1/2 of course is reporting it
but what not the number 14 which is
which term I want the actual term so I
will then say so 14 and then I'm just
going to chuck it into my formula right
which gives me what 108 takeaway
80 plus 32
that's 112 which is negative which kind
of is what you expected right because
you're starting in a hundred which is
almost a multiple of eight and then
you're going to end a takedown and
that's we